- [Voiceover] So in previous videos,
we worked out an expression
for the current i in an
LC circuit like this,
and what we found
was that i is square root of
capacitance over inductance,
times the starting voltage, V knot,
times sine omega knot t.
And omega knot is the natural frequency,
and we say that omega knot
was equal to square root
of one over L times C.
And V knot is the starting
voltage on the capacitor.
And our original assumption
was that i was zero to begin with,
and that's the expression for the current.
So what I wanna do now
is a specific example,
and we'll do that down here.
First I'm gonna install a switch
into our circuit so that
we can add some energy
and it won't go anywhere.
Then for C, C is gonna be
equal to a quarter of a farad,
and L is gonna be equal to one henry.
All right?
And on the capacitor, I'm
gonna put enough charge
to bring this up to 10 volts
before we close the switch.
And then at time equals
zero, we'll close the switch.
And what we wanna find is, what is i of t?
We have L, we have C, we
have a starting voltage,
and so now we have everything we need
to work out the current.
Let's do that, okay?
So first off we'll do omega knot.
Omega knot equals one over
the square root of LC,
so that equals
square root of one over one
henry times one quarter farad,
which equals square root of four,
or equals two,
and that's in units of radians per second.
That's the natural frequency.
We know the natural frequency right here,
and now we can work out the rest of it.
So we can just fill in i
equals square root of C,
which is one quarter farad,
divided by one henry,
times V knot.
V knot was was 10 volts
times sine omega knot t.
Sine, omega knot is two t.
And finally, i equals,
this is the square root of
one quarter or one half,
so that's one half,
times 10 is five, i equals five sine 2 t.
So for this specific circuit,
that's the answer for this current here.
Now I wanna show you what
that actually looks like.
So this is a plot of i of
t equals five sine two t.
And this is what a sine
wave looks like with time,
so the axes are time in seconds,
and this axis goes up to five amperes
and then down to minus five amperes
and continues on that way, and
it basically goes on forever.
Now what I wanna do next is work out
the voltage in the circuit.
We didn't talk about the voltage yet.
So I'll sketch the circuit again here.
Here's L and C.
And this is the voltage right here,
voltage across both guys.
We've already worked out i.
And now we wanna find v.
What's v?
That's what we're looking for.
So, we know that i equals five sine two t,
and to find v, one of
the easy ways to find v
is to use the inductor equation.
We know that v equals L di/dt.
That's just the basic
inductor i v equation, right?
And let's see what happens here.
v equals L is one, times di/dt.
So that's d/dt of 5 sine two t.
Now let's take that derivative, okay?
I'll go up here.
v equals five comes out of the derivative.
Sine two t.
The derivative of sine of two t
is two times cosine of two t.
All right?
So our voltage solution
is 10 times cosine two t.
So something interesting
just happened here.
Let me show you.
We started with the current
being a sine function,
and we eventually took the
derivative of that sine function
and now we have a cosine function.
So we went from sine
to cosine for voltage.
That means the voltage doesn't look
quite exactly like the current, okay?
Let me show you a plot of the voltage.
Here's the voltage here.
This is v of t.
And that we decided was
equal to 10 cosine two t.
Starts at a value of 10,
the time equals zero,
and then forms a cosine
wave that goes up and down
between plus and minus 10 volts.
Now let me show you what it looks like
when we plot both i and
v on the same graph,
and we can see the timing
relationship between them.
So this is a plot of i of t in blue,
and v of t in orange.
One them is a sine wave,
the current is a sine wave,
and voltage is a cosine wave.
So this is what we were going for.
This is the natural
response of an LC circuit,
and we had two specific
component values in it.
We saw that we came out with
both current and voltage
looking like sinusoidal waves.
This LC circuit,
this is where sine waves
come from in electronics.
It's pretty cool.